Home Alone is undeniably a Christmas classic.
How could anyone not love it?
It tells the story of a young boy, Kevin McCallister,
who's accidentally left behind when his family
leaves for a Christmas vacation.
To make matters worse, two burglars have targeted
the McCallister house while Kevin is there
by himself.
Unfortunately, that's also where things kind
of start to break down.
Kevin defends his homestead by setting up
a series of elaborate and dangerous traps
in order to stop the bad guys from robbing
the place...instead of, you know, calling
the cops.
And that's just one of many of the dumb things
in Home Alone that everyone just ignored.
Call the police
What's the first thing that every kid learns
to do when they realize they're in danger?
"Didn't they teach you that in school about
911 that you call if somebody needs help?"
"Yep."
"Yaaa"
Either Kevin didn't get the memo, or he just
doesn't have the mental capacity of a four-year-old.
Sure, the phone lines are down, but he knows
how to get into town to go food shopping,
and he knows exactly when Harry and Marv will
be robbing his house.
Kevin only dials 911 near the end of the film,
after the crooks have made their way through
almost all of his traps.
Even weirder, when he finally calls the cops,
he disguises his voice and tells them his...neighbor's
address?
Why was that the plan?
Did he think the cops would hear a child's
voice calling for help on 911 and they wouldn't
come?
Or maybe it's because...
The cops in this town suck
"Well he's just home alone and I would like
somebody to go over to the house and see that
he's alright just to check on him."
"You want us to go to your house just to check
on him?"
The cops of Home Alone are basically garbage
with badges.
When they're informed about a small child
left without supervision, they send one police
officer to the McAllister house.
The cop knocks on the door and then arbitrarily
decides Kevin's mom just can't keep track
of her children because no one answers.
Maybe that's why the Wet Bandits don't seem
concerned in the slightest when Kevin makes
multiple threats to call the police.
"Hey!
I'm calling the cops!"
"Wait wait wait wait wait he wants us to follow
him.
I got a better idea come on."
Harry and Marv simply ignore Kevin and continue
to invade his home.
They're already guilty of breaking and entering,
and they're attempting to assault a minor,
so the charges would probably be pretty severe,
but because Kevin lives in a town full of
Paul Blarts, there's really no reason for
them to worry.
Even the pizza boy has lost hope
Home Alone must happen in some dystopian alternate
reality where the law simply doesn't matter.
When Kevin plays the audio from an old gangster
movie to make the pizza guy think he's about
to get murdered, there are absolutely no consequences.
(gunshots)
Apparently, this kid just went back to delivering
more pizzas and never warned anyone about
the spray of gunfire that just took out half
of the neighborhood's inflatable Santas.
Marv doesn't know how TV works
The pizza boy scene is weird, but Kevin uses
the same trick on Marv as he tries to break
in the back door.
It worked on the especially stupid pizza boy
because Kevin only played certain parts of
the conversation, making the pizza boy believe
that he was talking to a real person.
And we all know that pizza boys are dumb.
"People said I was dumb, but I proved them!"
But when Marv comes to the door, Kevin just
plays the movie.
Sure, Kevin adds his own special effects,
but has Marv never heard a TV before?
How does this work?
Why is this happening?
"Is this real life?"
Uncle Frank is a monster
So we've talked about how the movie's suburban
hellscape is filled with morons.
But we can't let Kevin's clan off the hook:
the McCallister family is a bunch of hot garbage.
While it makes sense that Kevin might get
picked on by his older siblings and cousins,
why are the adult McCallisters straight up
bullying an eight-year-old?
When it comes to the steaming pile of awful
human trash that is this family, Uncle Frank
lives at the top.
When Kevin gets into a fight with Buzz — who
was pretending to throw up on Kevin, by the
way — some soda gets spilled on Uncle Frank's
lap.
Kevin didn't even do it; it was Kevin's useless
dad.
So, naturally Uncle Frank loses it.
"Look what you did, you little jerk!"
Nobody defends Kevin, not his parents, and
not even the kid from Pete & Pete.
"Kevin, you're such a disease."
Frank is a middle-aged adult with some very
deep psychological issues.
Forget Harry and Marv, if anyone deserves
a nail through the foot, it's Frank.
The McCallisters may all be monsters
Kevin's mom has to rush back home because
they can't get in touch with anybody to look
in on Kevin, but how is that possible?
The entire town didn't go away for Christmas.
Kevin goes to school and even mentions that
he has friends.
So why can't his parents call one of their
families, or any of the friends of Kevin's
seven thousand siblings?
Is there literally no one in the entire state
of Illinois that the McCallisters can trust
to check up on Kevin?
Kevin is going to kill his family
Remember how Harry and Marv kept falling down
the stairs because they were covered with
ice?
Or how the basement steps were covered in
tar and nails?
Kevin's massive family was basically walking
into a death trap by the end of the movie.
Kevin isn't exactly the most conscientious
kid, and he's even pretty happy about the
possibility that he's psychically murdered
them...
"I made my family disappear."
...so it's incredibly unlikely that the kid
cleaned up after himself.
Hopefully, Uncle Frank cracks his melon on
those icy steps first.
"Hey pizza's here!"
"Here you go, that's $122.50."
"Uh it's my brother's house he'll take care
of it."
"Your name's Kevin?
You know what they're gonna call you in France
don't you huh?"
"No."
"Yank!"
Ugh.
We really hate that guy.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!